I'm at the Laugh Factory with Daliya and
this girl reals herself by you know when
you will yourself by your hand your leg
is in a cast but you have your knee on
top of the on the scooter yeah yeah soon
when you have knee surgery maybe I don't
know what yeah ankle so pretty pretty
woman probably a little bit older and
audio man I'm not older 35 but very
pretty and I say she goes kind of so
great something nice about my stand up
something I said oh thanks I go what
happened your foot and she goes oh
you'll never believe it and I go what
happened she goes well because it was it
was wrapped in a weird thing it wasn't
in like a regular booty and I said I
said what happened she goes well I was
in Thailand and an elephant leaned
kneeled on my foot I was petting it in
the element foot and I go oh my god is
your foot crushed she goes well yeah but
also the skin on the all the skin on the
top my foot just peeled off all because
when the thing [ __ ] leaned on it
it's just wet [ __ ] and the skin just
went rolled off so the top here about a
pressure oh yeah all the skin on the
front just goes well see you later yeah
why don't we til pull the skin off and
then why don't we crush all the bones
while we're at it flat your foot out sir
she's all bunched up and the elephant
looked like it was about to roll on are
like leaning on her because she was
scratching it it was like asking a
[ __ ] thing good which is like I like
that yeah they had they it was hard to
go if they break out it was like wait
what happens no idea I know you know he
ripped the skin off I was just leaning
on that [ __ ] must are well I mean horses
will step on your foot then when you're
brushing them they'll just make a
mistake and step on your foot and it's
so painful there's a picture locked out
never straight this picture when my wife
got bitten by by a horse on the ass yeah
remember that yeah dad she was bending
over and she shouldn't have been in the
stool he was in a bad mood and she sent
me a picture of her ass and oh my god I
don't post horses I sure as [ __ ] don't
with elephants they kill you
horses close and kill you oh yeah oh
[ __ ] with any of them yeah Jesus Christ
man
that's like my buddy Bob Bob at the
airport this very heavy woman it's with
her husband and Bob's like mr. strong
man she got hit by a car it pushed her
it hit her lightly but she fell back I
think it pinned her foot and she fell
back and and he goes he goes he goes and
guess what Brian I go away he goes
her foot came on and I go what he goes
yep her foot came off right I said he
goes it was only being held on by her
like her pants but it the broad like
that remember when it happened to Silva
yeah it would shoot like that and it
kind of it only the skin was holding on
to it though and she goes oh my foot and
her husband started to panic and yes I
got you and she was too big for her
husband to pick up but he's really
strong and he just picked her up she was
up fix it hold a hat Dickey thick you
must hold her foot hold her foot and
held the foot on there but her foot went
boom
right at the airport she went into shock
that's how it goes yeah the guy was
super rich my friend had no money I
couldn't give you money and no is that
[ __ ] I should have taken some money so a
man in New York went to the Rochester
Airport and while he walked through TSA
he was given a note by one of the women
working he was kind of confused when he
saw it because he goes to the airport
very often for work and he just kind of
grabbed them no and he was gonna leave
he overhears the woman laughing sang hey
aren't you gonna open it aren't you
gonna open it he opens the note and it
says you ugly no and do you honestly he
looked at her and they were kind of her
and a couple other workers were giggling
their friends oh no he said that he was
offended by it or anything and that it
was pretty clear to him that she was
just trying to play a joke but he
decided to actually tell her manager
just because yeah she ended up getting
fired but he just did it from the
standpoint of well I didn't find it
offensive but you never know who else
could have given the note he was trying
to pry saver hey let just she takes
liberties yeah but you ugly yeah you
know watch it you have a picture of the
guy yeah
you're nosy like really hideous no not
you strong wait is that the girl on the
right there no you'll see her right
there
I got handed a note I didn't really
think of too much of it I just kind of
kept going I have about 10 minutes to
kind of like call back to me are you
gonna open that are you gonna open it
are you gonna look or something like
that eventually he opened it and the
workers started laughing oh it's it you
ugly with three exclamation marks he
says at first he just thought it was
strange but then decided just because it
didn't know him doesn't mean it wouldn't
hurt other people in the face so where
does she know like she you know they
don't know each other at all and also
she's no peach to lie but what was it's
Ted is the most bizarre thing I can
think it's I mean fun is also awesome
nobody's in the line I'll say you're
just the one guy first of all you feel
like a loser you're lonely traveling
there's nobody around then oh by the way
you ugly [ __ ] off I'm traveling I'm
probably tired it's probably early in
the morning damn it no one around and no
one else is in on the joke you ugh it's
just her and then she's then she's fast
you know grammar sucks I think she she
had this in her pocket for a while and
wanted to wait until someone came and he
happened to be the person because
there's nobody in line there's
absolutely no one there it's about the
most bizarre thing I've seen I don't
know what to say about I it's so
reckless and just like not not funny at
all the funny part is there's no one
around
yeah okay and then should I you know are
you gonna read that he's like cool she's
all he I mean all right and this woman
she had two different dates I'll show
you the first one the first one was for
some reason she was with a date and then
he got pulled over and then he said I
might get arrested it was for some sort
of like you know ticket vial or you know
some sort of thing on his car that they
wanted to check okay I'll just play free
stop sticks disable if it's actually
funnier when you listen to it stop in
Palm Coast about 2:00 a.m. Thursday only
to learn the driver bailed out into some
woods leaving the passage
a woman to face the consequences we are
not identifying her because she's not
charged with a crime turns out the woman
had just met the Orlando area man on a
dating website and stopped at this Palm
Coast Denny's for dinner on the way to
her gets better when a deputy tried to
stop the vehicle for a tag violation
violation they told the woman he'd go to
jail so he raced off
he was exceeding the speed limit driving
very erratically she was very scared in
the vehicle she told us he got away
though yeah she knew him by two
different first names check this out so
wrong on Thursday was the victim in a
different incident also involving a man
last month an incident that turned
violent and was caught on camera what
that instance a man's woman was seeing
but trying to get away from Adel store
threw himself took it off attacked her
when she got out pounding her knocking
her unconscious he did that to her a
month ago a different day different Hey
a different person sessions do more than
knock door a knocked her out and then a
month later she went on a date with this
guy and then police pursuit and he ran
away now that guy should be cancelled
right that guy should go to jail that
guy would have yeah they get should not
be any movies yeah that's a different
story
that's real violence both those guys
maybe yeah you know sexual harassment I
talk all about you know what's been
going on in the news and I went to
Houston I had the [ __ ] most gnarly
experience where I was talking about
like getting my ass grabbed at work or
something and trying to figure out that
joke and this older woman in the houston
can't sluice at the improv
whatever that big beautiful improv that
and I was like yeah so when a guy grabs
your ass at work and this woman just
yelled out take the compliment and move
on
that's what I'm saying is it sure that's
a joke I was such a totally and it was
like [ __ ] like we are in such an echo
chamber in LA and this is so tone deaf
in terms of like what the average woman
experiences the average man - I have a
lot of friends who are waitresses that I
went to school with that are like I
flirt for tips yeah sex is the only
power I have so we're in a weird bubble
and it [ __ ] blew my mind that I was
like I'm only hearing one point of view
and that's not healthy and that doesn't
make for good comedy and I really want
this to be a fair special sure yeah I've
never been I was there when it was a
communist really 1985 was it fun it was
the most oppressive greatest place in
the world but I was with my friend spoke
fluent Russian and I have with all these
kids jeans Nikes cars they didn't have
anything like wait this is blowing my
mind yes
when was that I was in high school
senior in high school so the night snow
bunnies and hooked up with my first
threesome there my first threesome
really with two 21 year olds you're I'm
Christina and my buddy chickened out
couldn't get a hard-on a little [ __ ]
baby and I did you were mom the guy was
he was next to me Chloe little [ __ ]
baby so it's just me the fact that you
were there is why he couldn't get was
older than me christina was trying to
get him gone he couldn't do it he was
like dude yeah insane bet so why did say
their bed next to me so Svetlana they
were so hot so Christina so you get he
freaks out goes out so Christina comes
over to my bed the first time I've been
with two girls I'm like holy bug so I go
to town and then my friend comes when
I'm like Brian Jim but it's in the
cosmos hotel the biggest hotel in the
world my friend comes I was you're Brian
your mother's downstairs it was a
two-story suite I go what just [ __ ] your
mother's downstairs - I'm 18 I pull my
jeans on I go I look down and my mom and
the railing my mom goes and I go how did
you find me she goes I'm a witch and I
know where you are and I checked that my
sister was sick I wasn't in the room she
walked biggest hotel in the world
biggest
found me because the door was cracked
mother can smelled you [ __ ] it she
didn't hear me [ __ ] Svetlana comes
out completely naked looks down and my
mother goes well see why you're here I
we come back down we drank caviar
we ate caviar Jewish drank vodka with
your mom with my mom until for a week
where did your mom come from I was on a
family trip with my mother did your mom
was in Russia also CIA oh I was like
Jesus your mother died yeah well I grew
up overseas remember I didn't move this
guy I tell us fort I know nothing about
you mom
I know I move the states when I was 14
okay I'd never lived in the country
until I was 14 I lived in seven
different countries I know that you want
to do another couple hour specials on
birds but you should talk about that
that is so [ __ ] I know you're doing
ostriches next with all like the pigeon
head movements but goddamn it matters
more to me than just that weird [ __ ]
amazing yeah the basically if someone's
watching you do [ __ ] around on
Instagram with Chris like I want to see
you do that I don't see you be someone I
got I got a Chris send me the funniest
thing I got a post today about oh my god
you do it right now no but did you and
Chris get along at first yeah really
right right yeah best hmm did I know cuz
i when i was younger though he was just
i remember i hold was you any met him
cuz 1h or something when we started
because Chris and I basically started at
the same I would say you and Chris were
friends right off the bat I knew Chris
maybe was married yeah me too but you
were Fred right like right when you guys
came to LA you guys were friends mother
I guess huh no we do it each other
Whitney what are you talking I know but
you were senior to me yeah so I was like
oh that's Bryan Callen yeah but we knew
each other but yeah but you guys but we
didn't like to do the same no you were
doing clubs I was doing like rooms yes
you and Chris came here at the same time
we're friends right away we were friends
we met at a lot in Long Beach at some
[ __ ] stand-up she's a horrible
stand-up show at like a bowling alley
and we were sick instant yeah instant
friends I mean he's weird he was like I
remember being like thinking he was like
kind of a weirdo you know cuz he I used
his torture him and I love that Carly I
he'd luck he got the joke yeah so I used
to just you know I'd be like you died
say things like let me borrow your wife
for the weekend I got these Russian guys
Tommy you can't borrow my wife - and if
he was married before
yeah I mean there's a lot of Connick is
there's so many comics and now that in
the beginning we like it's not that we
didn't get along it's just we never were
friends and then now we're so close and
you remember those years where we like
weren't friends yeah like it's just so
wild you just were all it's a small
fraternity yeah and it's like we all
know what's up it's like it's a small
fraternity yeah like I see comics in
airports that I've never met before and
we're just like instant family and then
we're like this is our first time
meeting so we're all doing the same
starting tomorrow or 50 years yeah yeah
and there's something very like when
when I'm so drogon myself 10,000 takes
Bill burr may sell 10,000 tickets when
we're at The Comedy Store
Dadda [ __ ] goes out the window we're all
just comics yeah and oh by the way
you're as good as the last joke you
wrote this doesn't get easier for
anybody it's not like I'm a master at
comedy now and I can just get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah bu er you've always
been so [ __ ] funny in such range like
ridiculously for a different way they
used to I definitely been jealous of you
before it's a gift